many have called this a battle which
means for this paramedic this isn't just
an apron it's a shield the apron been in
PVC apron obviously it doesn't pop up
the uniform along with gloves and a
surgical facemask this is what the
government says is safe enough for
day-to-day interactions with a confirmed
or suspected covert 19 case but this
paramedic wanted to speak out this kit
he says is putting people at risk
initially where we struggled with
supplies of PPE well getting lots of
supplies of PPE but now it seems like a
lot of it is substandard and appropriate
a lot of us feel that we we end up
wearing a uniform 12 12 hour shift the
if you've entered someone house that is
possibly got Kovac 19 that uniforms not
being covered properly you don't feel
you want to leave one patient to walk
into a care home and then plug that
virus in a care home fits a fit to
spread around elderly high risk patients
and unfortunate that's probably going to
happen what this paramedic wants is more
robust protection like this but it's
currently only recommended when in
high-risk areas or doing more invasive
procedures it can leave paramedics
heading into the unknown feeling exposed
we have been finding that a lot of PPE
has been distributed to a wider part of
the healthcare system and for ambulance
services they do seem to be struggling
to try and get that supply of personal
protective equipment
it is incredibly challenging and I think
what we need to do is we just need to
make sure that the paramedics the
frontline health care professional is
not forgotten public health England told
us their protective equipment guidelines
match that of the World Health
Organization but that they would soon be
updating them but how they didn't say
I'm sure it will come through eventually
but that's the unfortunate thing
we're already in the middle of this
it should have been there in the first
place we shouldn't be having to model
our way through it
feeling unprotected it does make you
feel vulnerable and right now these are
key workers we can't afford to lose
Caterina vertices Sky News